[music]
changing world order
entry
future times will be radically
different from what we have experienced in
our lives although they will be similar to
what happened many times in the past
how do I know because it has
always been
[music]
for about 50 years of global
macroeconomic investment  I found out from
bitter experience that the most important
event surprised and amazed me only
because in my life they
had never happened before.
These little pleasant surprises prompted
me to study the history of the last 500 years in
search of similar situations and then I
realized that in the past they happened
many times in time  the rise and fall of the
Dutch
British and
American empires and
yet each time such situations were a
sign of a changing world order
from this study I have learned valuable lessons
summarized here in
full they are set out in my books
principles of existence in a changing
world order
let me start with the story that
led me  at this point about how i
learned to foresee the future by studying the
past
how i learned to foresee the future by studying the
debts just like that and the United States
ran out of money how is it possible
then gold was used as money in transactions between
countries
paper money such as the dollar looked like
a check in a checkbook their only
value was that they
could be exchanged for gold which
was genuine  money at that time the
united states were spending much more
money than they were earning by writing much
more of this paper money checks than
there was gold in the bank to
exchange as people brought these checks
in the bank to exchange for gold the amount of
gold in the usa was declining it soon became
apparent that the usa  cannot keep their
promises to secure all issued
into circulation of paper money, so people
rushed to exchange their dollars for
gold before it
ran out, realizing that the US would soon run out of real money, that is, backed by gold money on Sunday evening August 15, President Nixon went on television
and told the world that the US was breaking its
promises to allow people to exchange their
dollars back of course he delivered the
news more diplomatically without making it clear
that the united states is becoming
insolvent the
value of national currencies is based
on the strength of the country's economy and the US
economy is by far the strongest in the
world
accordingly I instructed the secretary of the
treasury to take measures necessary to
protect dollars from speculators
I instructed secretary john  channel temporarily
suspend the conversion of dollars of
gold or other reserve assets,
except for amounts and conditions in the
interests of the stability of the monetary
system and the vital interests of the
United States,
I listened to this speech in horror, realizing that  oh
money as we understood it ends
in countries a real crisis
i expected the stock
market to fall the next day so i went to the
exchange early to get ready when the
first bell rang pandemonium broke out
but not like i expected the
market rushed up exactly up and rose by
almost twenty  five percent
I was amazed because I
had never experienced a currency devaluation
before when I delved into history I found
that the same thing happened in
1933 and had the same effect
then paper dollars were also
pegged to gold which the US was
running out of because  that the nation's spending
in paper money checks exceeded the
value of the holding stock of
collateral or gold and President
Roosevelt announced on the radio that he was
renouncing the government's promise to
exchange dollars for an umbrella
just then I issued an executive order for a
nationwide suspension of
banking operations and this was the first
step of the government to restore our and
financial and economic structure, the second
step last Thursday was a
bill passed quickly and patriotically by Congress
approving my decree and expanding my
authority, which allowed, given the
demands of the time, to extend this
suspension and
gradually lift the ban on banking graces over several days,
this law also gave the authority
to develop programs
in both cases, breaking the link with gold
allowed the usa to continue spending more
than they were earning just print
more paper dollars as the
number of dollars increased without
increasing the wealth of the country, the
value of each dollar
added when these new dollars entered the
market without a corresponding increase in
productivity
they went to buy a large number of
shares  gold and commodity exchanges traded
what caused their prices
to rise as I studied history I learned that in the
past the same thing happened many
many times
I learned that from time immemorial as
soon as  the government started to spend
much more than they received in
taxes and circumstances got worse
they ran out of money but the need
for it grew so they kept
printing more and more and
much more which led to a drop in the
value of money and rising prices for everything
including stocks Rivia gold commodities
that's when I first learned the following
principle when central banks print a
lot of money to alleviate the crisis, you need
to buy shares of gold and commodities
because their value will rise and the
cost of paper money
year to mitigate the
economic crisis caused by the
pandemic, this will almost certainly
happen in the future, so I advise you to
remember this principle
[music]
all this allowed me to formulate
another principle to understand what
awaits you, you need to understand what
happened in the past, this principle
made me study  how the roaring twenties bubble
turned into the 1930 depression and these
lessons allowed me to anticipate and capitalize on the
2007 bubble turned into the 2008 crash
all these encounters with reality
led me to almost
instinctively search the past for a similar
situation in order to learn
deal with the future correctly
changes in the world order
[music]
I was motivated to do this research by three
important events that took place over the past
few years that I had not
encountered before, firstly, it turned out that the
state did not have enough money to
pay its debts even after lowering
interest rates to 0 percent, and
therefore  their central banks began to
print a lot of money in the second growth of
wealth inequality and
opposition to cyanide led to major
internal conflict they appeared in
political populism and polarization
between the left seeking the
redistribution of wealth and the right
who want to protect those who
we own it and thirdly, the growing
external conflict between a growing
great power and a leading great
power, as it is now happening with
China and the United States,
so I took up the history of the issue and saw
that all this had happened before
and many times and almost always
led to a change in the internal  and the
world order, the last time
such a sequence of events
took place in 1930
1945, what is such a device in this
case, you ask, this is a system for
controlling the masses of people
interacting with each other in different
countries, there are different systems of
government, ordinary complex
constitutions, and there is a world
legal order that regulates relations
between countries  and the
change in the
state structure and the order of
government of individual countries usually set forth in international treaties does not coincide
with problems with the variables of the world of devices,
but in both cases these changes
usually occur after wars of civil
wars within the country and out between countries
it happens to us when new revolutionary
forces defeat the weak old park,
for example, the state structure of the usa
was set out in the constitution of
1789 adopted after the american
revolution and is still in force even
after the civil war in the usa
russia got rid of its old
state the device was established
as a result of the revolution of 1917  and in
1991, this order would have changed
as a result of a relatively bloodless
revolution, today's
state structure in China dates back to
1949, when the Chinese Communist Party
won the civil war, that
is, the idea is understandable, the current
world order, usually called the
American world order, was formed
after the victory of the Allies in World
War II, when  sasha became the dominant
world day, this world order
formulated the agreements and
international treaties governing the
global government and the functioning of
monetary systems, the basis of the new world
monetary system was
laid  the Tton Woods Accords,
whereby the dollar became the world's leading
reserve currency, the
reserve currency is
the world's accepted currency and its presence is a
key factor in turning the country into
the richest and most powerful
empire
with the establishment of a new dominant force
and monetary system, a new
world order is being built these changes  take place
in an ram time universal cycle
which i call
most the
great cycle i will start with a brief
overview then give you a more complete
description and at the end if you want to know
more I will give a link to my book in the course of
studying the 10 most powerful empires
of the last 500 years and the last three
reserve currencies we think of with a glance
passed the ups and downs of the fall of the
dutch empire and the guilder of the
british empire and the pound sterling the
rise and fall of the empire of the
united states and the dollar and the
decline and rise of the chinese empire and its
currencies and the rise and fall of the spanish
german french  The Indian Japanese
Russian and Ottoman Empires along with
major conflicts in these countries as
shown in this diagram
to better understand the Chinese model, I
also studied the rise and fall of the Chinese
dynasties of their money up to 600
AD,
because at the same time and considering
all these indicators can be
confusing  i will focus on the four
most important dutch british
american and chinese you will quickly
notice a pattern
now let's simplify the logic a
bit as you can see all of these changes
took place in overlapping
cycles that lasted about 250 years with
10 to 20 year transition periods between
usually these transition periods were
times  large-scale conflicts because
the leading powers do not give up without a fight and
since I measure the power of any empire in
this study, I used 8
system indicators. The measure of the total
power of each side is obtained by
averaging them integrally.
development innovative technological development
competitiveness in world markets
production volumes share in world
trade
military power the potential of the financial
center of the country in the capital markets
strength and stability of the country's currency as
a reserve currency since these
systemic indicators are measured and we can
see how strong each country is
now whether it was strong  in the past, and
increases or decreases, and power,
studying the sequence of events in
many countries, you can see how a
typical cycle unfolds,
since particulars can distort the general
pattern and let's simplify the course of
reasoning and focus on the
structure of typical cause-and-effect
relationships that determine the rise and fall of
any empire,
as we see qualitative  education
usually leads to innovative
technological development and, although with
some delay in the approval of the
national currency as children, it is
equally true that
subsequently
degraded  the
collapse of one leads
to the fall of the other
now consider the typical
sequence of events within a country
causing these ups and downs
in a nutshell a big cycle usually
starts after a major conflict
often after you and the emergence of a new major
power and a new world order
because no one  dares to
challenge that power this is usually
followed by a period of peace and prosperity
as people become accustomed to peace and
prosperity
they bet more and more on
their preservation and continuation they borrow
money for this which eventually
leads to a financial bubble the share of the
empire in  world trade is growing and
when most transactions are made in
its currency, this currency becomes a
reserve one, which stimulates further
and even more borrowing
at the same time, the
uneven distribution of growing
wealth increases, that is, the wealth
gap usually widens.
I wait for the rich haves and the
poor for the have-nots, in the end the
financial bubble bursts, which leads
to an increase in the volume of emission of money and an increase in
internal conflict between the rich and the
poor, and this leads to a revolution in one
form or another for the redistribution of
wealth, it occurs either
peacefully or in the form of Don  while the
empire struggles with this internal
conflict and its power is dwindling
compared to rising rival powers
when a new rising star gains
enough strength to compete with the
dominant power
internal conflicts arise external
conflicts most often wars from these
internal and external wars emerge new
winners and losers
then the victors come together to
establish a new world order and the cycle
begins again
in retrospect I saw that since the
Roman Empire it was these
causal relationships that were the
root cause of the cycles of ups and downs I
saw as a plot and each of these
cycles  intertwine with each other before
during and after each cycle, just
as each individual plot is intertwined
with others forming a 500-year epic our
common history
just like human life cycles, no
two are exactly the same, but most of
them are similar in their driving forces and
cause-and-effect relationship  which
goes through a series of stages
from birth to maturity and power and then to
weakening and inevitable decline,
however, this is like saying that the
life and cycle of a person on average takes
80 years without realizing that many of them are
much shorter and many longer although the
age can be good
health indicators speak better about life expectancy, the same is
true for the
empire and their vital signs, I
found that by watching the signs of a
change of power, you can see at what
stage the country is, and this helped
me to foresee what could happen
next,
now I will introduce in more detail  you with a
big cycle in 20 minutes i ra  I
will tell you about the last 500 years of history and
show similar patterns in the development of the
Dutch British American and
Chinese empires
500 years of great cycles
consider a typical cycle by dividing it into
3 phases
rise peak and decline
rise The
authors of successful new orders, both
internal and external,
are usually influential revolutionary
leaders  those who carry out 4 transformations
firstly they gain power
thanks to a more powerful support of which their
opponent secondly they consolidate
power by converting weakening or
eliminating opponents by eliminating them from
their path thirdly they create a
social system institutions thanks to
which the country functions at
least acceptable and in  fourth, they
select their successors well or create a
reliable system of selection, since a great
empire needs several great
leaders for several
generations at this stage, soon after a
victorious struggle for power,
a period of peace usually follows  and growing
prosperity, because the leadership of the
country is clearly dominated and enjoys
wide support, and therefore no one
wants to conflict with it at this stage, the
national leadership should
develop an excellent system for
increasing the welfare and power of the
country, first of all, the greatness of the state is
determined by the following factors a
thorough education, not only
giving knowledge and skills  but also those who form a
strong character, citizenship and
hardworking, they are usually taught in family schools
and religious institutions; this
ensures a healthy respect for the
rules and laws; order in society; a
low level of corruption;
the production of basic
products innovative technological
development,
for example, the Dutch who rebelled against
the Habsburg empire became excellently
educated people thanks to their
ingenuity, a quarter of
all major inventions in the world appeared on their own  The first
important of which was ocean ships
allowing you to travel around the world and
accumulate huge wealth, as well as the
invention of capitalism as we
know it today to finance these
travels,
they, like all leading empires,
improved their thinking by being
open to everything and advanced world thought
as a result, people and the country become
more productive and more
competitive in world markets,
which is manifested in the growth of production volumes
and the growth of their share in world
trade, which is
exactly what is happening today in the United States and
China are approximately comparable both in
terms of production volume and hem in
world trade
as the scope of trade of countries
is becoming more and more  globally they have
to protect their trade routes and their
foreign interests attack and to
do this build up their military power
if done right this virtuous
cycle leads to high
income growth which can be used
to invest in building
infrastructures  In research and
development,
such countries should also
develop incentive and empowerment systems
for those who have the ability to
earn or gain
wealth. In all these cases, the most
successful empires have used the
capitalist approach to develop a
class of productive entrepreneurs.
capitalist
approach
[music]
when Deng Xiaoping was asked about it, he
said it doesn’t matter whether it’s a white cat or a black one, the
main thing is that it catches mice
and it’s nice to be rich is the
key to the success of countries in this development of
their own capital markets, primarily
bond lending markets and stock markets, this
allows people to convert their
savings in investments to
finance inventions and developments
and
getting their share of success in those who
do great things the
Dutch created the first joint-stock
company the Dutch East India
Company and 1 fund  new market for its
financing which became
integral parts of a system that
produced enormous wealth and
power, the
natural consequence was that the
greatest empire creates and the
world's leading financial centers to
attract and distribute world
capital amsterdam was the world
financial center when the Dutch ruled
london when the British were at the top
now it is  new york but china is rapidly
developing its financial centers
most importantly the capitalists governments
and the military should work closely together not
only did the dutch cooperate well
they were a single entity the
government granted the dutch
east india company a trading monopoly
and it had its own officially
sanctioned and armed forces
to  to enter world markets and
create and acquire wealth the
British followed in their footsteps and created the
British East India Company with
similar coordination of their
government's business and military interests.
the us
military industrial complex and
today's chinese system followed suit
when a country becomes the largest
international trading empire and
trade transactions can be paid for in its
own currency making this
currency the preferred global
medium of exchange and because this currency is
so widespread and often
used by people in  all over the world want to
keep their savings in it, which is what
you do and the preferred store of
wealth and therefore the
world's leading reserve currency
when the Dutch led world
trade the main world reserve
currency was gulden when the British pound
sterling and since the leadership was
taken over by the us the us dollar is
naturally as a reserve currency
China's currency is increasingly being used
having a reserve currency allows an
empire to borrow more than other
countries
this advantage is huge
think about it people all over the world tend to
save and therefore
lend currency to their empire  in many countries without a
reserve currency, this is not the case, and when the
empire runs out of its own money,
remember the usa
1971, the empire can always
print more
exorbitant privilege granted to the
empire by the reserve currency leads to
an increase in borrowing and the beginning of the growth of the
financial bubble
this is a sequence of
causal relationships leading
mutual support of financial political
and military  forces
backed by the creditworthiness of the
reserve currency was formed already at the
beginning of recorded history
all the empires of the world reached the heights of
power went to them therefore the
peak
[music]
although in the upper phase most of these
strengths are preserved in the fruits of their
success the seeds of their decline are planted as a
rule because the people in these rich and
powerful countries earn
more this makes their labor more expensive
and less competitive compared
to people from other countries who are willing
to work for less pay while
people in other countries
naturally cop  methods and technologies are used by the
leading powers, which further reduces
its competitiveness,
for example, the labor of British
shipbuilders was less expensive than that of the
Dutch,
so the British hired Dutch
designers to design
high-quality ships that were then
built by less expensive British
workers, and this increased their
competitiveness, which led to the
rise of the British and the decline  of the Dutch
besides the richer the people the less
they work they enjoy
more leisure the more refined and
less productive pursuits in life and
in extreme cases this leads to decay
in times of ascent to the top
values ​​change from generation to
generation from those who have had
to struggle to achieve wealth  and
power down to those who inherited them it is
they who are less battle-hardened surrounded by
luxury and accustomed to an easy life which
makes them more vulnerable to the
difficulties of the
golden age of the Dutch Empire
and the
Victorian bad British  tsev
[music]
[applause]
were just such periods of
prosperity as people get used to the fact
that everything is going well, they increasingly
bet that good times will
last forever and in the pursuit of this I
borrow money, resulting in the
formation of so-called financial
bubbles naturally uneven
financial well-being leads to a
growing gap in wealth
this gap widens under the influence of
positive feedback as the
resources of the rich allow them to further
strengthen their financial situation
e.g. their children receive significant
privileges e.g. better education and
their parents influence the political
system in their interests  this leads to a
widening gap in policy values
and opportunities between the rich haves and the
poor have-nots
those who are less well off consider this
state of affairs unfair and therefore
their dissatisfaction is growing but so far the standard of
living of most people continues to grow
these gaps  s and grievances do not escalate into
open conflict
having a world reserve currency
inevitably leads to excessive
borrowing and encourages a
country to accumulate large debts to
foreign creditors
although in the short term it
increases purchasing power in the
long term it hurts the
country's financial health and
weakens its currency in other ways.  in words, when
borrowing and spending a great empire
looks powerful but in fact
its finances are weakening,
borrowing allows the authorities of a country to deviate
from its basic principles by financing both
domestic excess consumption by surrendering and
international military conflicts
necessary to keep the empire
afloat, the
costs of maintaining and protecting the empire
inevitably exceed income  which it
brings, therefore, the possession of the empire
becomes unprofitable.
the opean powers
to protect their territory and
trade routes in the same way the british
empire became a huge zero
bath bureaucrats and lost its competitive
edge as rival
powers grew especially germany which led to
an increasingly costly arms race
and a world war since
september 11, 2001 the united states have spent
about 8  trillions of dollars for
foreign wars and their aftermath and
trillions more for other military operations and
support of military bases in 70 countries and these
expenditures are still not enough to
continue the military rivalry with
China in its border areas in this
cycle, richer countries will
end up mired in debt  borrowing money
from poorer countries that save
more is one of the first signs
of wealth and power changing
hands this process began in the United
States in the 1980s when per
capita income was 40 times higher than in
China and the US government
began  take loans from the Chinese
just as the British borrowed a
lot of money from their much poorer
colonies and the Dutch did the same
at the height of their power
when the empire was unable to get a
holder for them from their new creditors  and
currencies you start looking to sell and
get rid of it rather than buy hoarding
lending and receiving and
[music] the
power of the empire starts to
wane you find the
decline is due to internal
economic weakness coupled with
internal or costly external
conflicts or both
usually  in the beginning, the decline comes
gradually
and then it suddenly increases when the
size becomes very large for a long time
, an economic recession sets in and the empire
can no longer borrow the money
necessary to pay off the debts the
financial bubble bursts
this creates great internal difficulties
and puts states before the choice of
defaulting on their debts  din or printing a
lot of new money, the
state always prefers to
print a lot of new money, first
gradually and then more and more often
this depreciates the currency and accelerates
inflation
for the Dutch, the financial crisis was
caused by financial excesses and
paying for the 4th Anglo-Dutch War
in the same way that the British paid for
their financial  the excesses and debts of the two
world wars and the usa has
gone through a tricycle of debt-financed booms and busts
since the 1990s, with the
central bank stepping in every time and
ever
more effectively
when the government is having trouble
financing its own operations
when the
economic downturn hits  and the
standard of living of most people is declining, and
all this in the presence of material
inequality,
inequality in values ​​and differences in
political interests, internal
conflicts between rich and poor, as
well as various technical
religious and different  groups are
increasing sharply this leads to political
extremism which manifests itself in the form of
populism of the left or right the
left seeks to redistribute
wealth rims seek to keep
wealth in the hands of the rich
states in the jurisdiction
assets and currencies in which they
feel more secure these attacks
reduce tax revenues to the treasury of the
empire, which leads to the classic
process of washing out capital with
positive feedback when
capital flight becomes serious enough the
government
outlaws it, who wants to get out of this
trap and begins  panic, this
unsettled environment is undermining the
productivity of the economy,
shrinking the economic pie
and sparking new conflicts over
how to share dwindling resources,
emerging populist leaders
from both countries  sides of the political spectrum promise
to take control of the situation and restore
order, this is when democracy
faces the greatest problems
because it cannot control
anarchy and this is when the most likely
transition of power to a strong
papulean leader who will bring order to chaos
as the conflict escalates within the country
this leads  to some form of
revolution or civil war to
redistribute wealth and effect the
necessary drastic changes, this
process can be peaceful while maintaining the
existing order but most often it is
accompanied by a violent change in this
order
e.g. Roosevelt's
wealth redistribution revolution was
relatively peaceful and maintained the
existing internal order
while the French and Russian
and
Chinese revolutions were much more
violent and led to a new internal
order,
this internal conflict rather makes the
empire weak and vulnerable to
increasing external rivals  those
who see this internal weakness are more
inclined to challenge the empire, this
increases the risk of a major international
conflict, especially if the enemy has created an
armed set comparable to the empire,
protecting himself and his empire from
rivals requires large military
expenses against the backdrop of a deteriorating internal
economic situation, and the empire
can least afford this  allow
because there is no viable system for the peaceful
resolution of international
disputes such a conflict is usually
resolved by real tests of
patronymics as the leading empire
faces increasingly bold
challenges it faces a difficult
choice to fight or retreat
fight lose the worst outcome but
retreat is also bad because it yields
rival a place in the race and sends a signal
of the weakness of the empire to those countries that are
considering which side to be on, the
unfavorable economic situation
intensifies the struggle between wealth and power, which
inevitably leads to its own growth.  yes to war
war is terribly expensive at the same
time they cause tectonic shifts
that reshape new orders
according to the new realities of wealth and
power in the world when holders of reserve
currencies and long-decaying
empires lose faith in them and sell them
this marks the end of her great cycle
of the approximately 750 currencies that have existed since
1700,
less than 20 percent currently exist and all of them
depreciated
for the Dutch this happened after their
defeats in the 4th Anglo-Dutch War
when they were unable to pay the huge
debts accumulated during the war this
led to a panic withdrawal from the
bank  Amsterdam and desperately selling
assets that forced the government
to resort to the largest and most unsatisfactory
which depreciated both the currencies of the empire and
the empire itself to almost complete
insignificance for the
British this happened after the second
world war when, despite their
victory, they were unable to pay the huge
debts on the loan taken to
finance
This led to a series of
devaluation and sell-offs in the British
pound as the US and the
dollar became dominant
at the time and created a new world order at the time of
this video the united states had not
reached that point yet wanted the US to have a huge
debt in the country spending more  how it
earns and finances this deficit
and through new loans and the printing of
huge amounts of new money, a large-scale
sale of dollars and good
things has not yet begun, and although for all classical
reasons there are large internal and
external conflicts, they have not yet reached the
line for which they turn into wars in the
final  out of these conflicts,
violent or not, new
winners emerge who come together and
restructure the debts and political
systems of the losers and establish a
new world order
then the old cycle and empires
ends and a new one begins and it all
repeats over and over again I
just dumped a lot of [ __ ] on you
It is not enough to paint a picture of the
development of a typical large cycle of
course not all such cycles happen
this way but in most cases they
are such and similar to each other so much
that it seems that the stories of ups and
downs remain essentially the same
the only thing that changes is the
outfits of the characters and the used  they have
technology and
so where does it all go
[music] the
future of the
majority of the empire has its own finest hour
after which they inevitably fall into
decline
it is difficult to reverse the decline because
it is necessary to cancel or destroy
much of what has already been done, but in
principle it is possible
looking at these indicators it is quite easy to
see at what stage of the big cycle
the empire is, how much it is
adapted to exist in the world,
whether its condition is improving or worsening,
this usually helps to estimate how many
years it has
left, however, such estimates are not accurate and the
cycle can be extended if
responsible persons turn  attention to
life is not showing  the authorities of the country and will improve them,
for example, knowing that a person is 60
years old, what is the state of his health,
khariton or not, and some other
basic vital indicators, you can
estimate his life expectancy; this
also applies to empires and their vital
indicators, such an assessment does not claim
to be accurate, but in general it will give  a good
idea of ​​​​the health of the nation and a clear
direction in which it is necessary to
act to prolong the existence of the
empire most often the biggest war of the
nation is waged by the cathedral itself and the essence of this
war is making the difficult decisions
necessary to consolidate success
as far as our tasks come down to
just two to
earn more than we  spending and being
nice to each other everything
else I mentioned good
education resourcefulness
competitiveness and so on these are
just ways to solve these two problems
and how well we solve them is easy
to measure in the same way that people who
want to get in shape should
do it  systematically and
thereby improve your vital signs
let's do this individually and in
crypto
I have shared with you this picture of the world of the
device and several principles for
surviving in this world with one goal to
help you understand where we are and
what problems we face and
also make the wise decisions
necessary  in order to
navigate well in these times
[music]
since there is still much to be discussed
and time is up, I advise you to
read in detail my book Principles of
Existence in a Changing World Order and
I look forward to continuing this
conversation on the economics principle forest website
.  orc and on social media thank you
and may the force of evolution be with you
[music]